I mean Cena's like they're pretty much
almost dead already no one's really
watching them so we should hold a
memorial service for them just like a
mock comedic one we're like it was and
we we go around the room say our
favorite moments that we had with CNN
mine was when the BLM protesters were
trying to burn down their offices when
they were talking about how great the
protests were that's my favorite uh if
you guys want to go around the table uh
feel free to tell us your favorite
memory
I felt like that was so fitting that
they went right up to their doorstep and
they were like we're ruining it to you
here we go my favorite one of my
favorite moments
um man this brings back memories you
guys you know I remember when there was
this viral meme of Anderson Cooper Waist
Deep in water
and then the the wide shot shows a guy
standing on the road in Anderson's just
like in the water for no reason find
beer or something Anderson Cooper's just
like oh so much wind and water that was
definitely like a formative memory of
going oh all right this guy's full of
[ __ ] right fake news yeah